[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
an meiner seite ist wieder norbert
lehmann für den sportlern schillernder
vor mir und wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
spd im stimmungshoch in umfragen liegt
die partei klar vor der union
kanzlerkandidaten laschet setzt im
endspurt auf ein sogenanntes
zukunftsteam
kaum in der schule schon in quarantäne
tausende kinder in nrw müssen zu hause
bleiben das soll sich ändern
ohne triumph über 400 meter bei den
paralympics holt johannes flores gold
auch andere deutsche athleten hatten
grund zum jubeln
es ist mehr als ein weckruf das aktuelle
zdf-politbarometer drei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl dürfte die parteien
ziemlich auffüllen zum ersten mal seit
19 jahren liegen die sozialdemokraten
formen und ihr kanzlerkandidat lässt die
beiden konkurrenten noch weiter hinter
sich damit sie gleich die wichtigsten
zahlen sehen fangen wir direkt mit
matthias fornoff an guten abend ein
abend was hat sich da verändert im
vergleich zur letzten woche hat sich
eine menge verändert es gibt viel
bewegung die spd zieht an der union
vorbei und wäre derzeit stärkste kraft
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union weiter auf 22 prozent ihren
bisher niedrigsten wert überhaupt die
spd 25 prozent plus 3 punkte
fd fw fdp 11 plus 1 linke 7 + 1 grüne 17
prozent -3
eine große koalition wäre so hauchdünn
möglich und mehrere dreierbündnisse
und wer ist als kanzler oder kanzlerin
geeignet olaf scholz trauern jetzt 70
prozent das amt zu nur 25 prozent halten
armin laschet für geeignet und 23%
annalena baerbock wie lässt sich die
stärke der spd erklären die guten werte
für ihren kanzlerkandidaten sind
natürlich das eine wir haben aber auch
gefragt welches thema besonders wichtig
ist für die eigene wahlentscheidung der
bürger und bürger und da sagen 51
prozent das ist die soziale
gerechtigkeit
mit abstand folgen klimaschutz corona
und flüchtlinge asyl und welche partei
kann am ehesten für soziale
gerechtigkeit sorgen da sehen wir ein
eindeutiges bild der spd trauen das 43
prozent der befragten zu mit großem
abstand vor allen anderen
person und thema passen also derzeit für
die spd dankeschön matthias wohnung noch
mehr spannende zahlen vom politbarometer
sehen sie wie immer im heute journal um
22 uhr und das ergebnis der
sonntagsfrage sowie alle übrigen angaben
können sie auch jederzeit nachlesen
online auf zdf heute und in unserer zdf
heute
angesichts der miserablen umfragewerte
wächst in der union die nervosität
csu-chef söder nannte die lage ernst und
alarmierend jetzt müsse man kämpfen
kanzlerkandidat laschet setzt auf die
zugkraft eines neuen tiefs aus berlin
ins trans ein sogenanntes zukunftsteam
soll es nun richten und die union aus
dem umfragetief holen polit neulinge
neben bekannten gesichtern diese bunt
zusammengesetzte gruppe will soziale
gerechtigkeit herausstellen aber auch
konservative stammen themen wie innere
und äußere sicherheit für mich war immer
wichtig dass die cdu als team sichtbar
wird und team ist für mich der
christlichsoziale der liberale und der
konservative flügel der partei mit dabei
terrorismus experte peter neumann aber
auch der ex fraktionschef und
konservative finanzpolitiker friedrich
merz und musikmanager george
erfuhr erst vor zwei tagen dass er dabei
sein soll das team eine panikreaktion
groß war der innerparteiliche druck auf
laschet geworden sich breiter
aufzustellen und zu zeigen was team war
richtig und notwendig und das kommt auch
jetzt zum richtigen zeitpunkt später
hätte es allerdings auch nicht sein soll
die spd vor der union ihr
spitzenkandidat warnt vor übermut als
sich dieser trend der umfrage gestern
erneut bestätigt
[Applaus]
die wahl ist am 26 september
man musste die bürgerinnen und bürger
überzeugen man muss demütig mit der
zustimmung und der freude umgehen die
wir auch hier stören die grünen
verlieren im politbarometer ihre
kandidatin scheint sich umso mehr von
beiden absetzen zu wollen union und spd
wir haben hier zur wahl ob wir ein
weiter so machen an dem wir wie armin
laschet und olaf scholz an der kohle für
17 jahre festhalten oder ob wir jetzt
die weichen dafür stellen wirklich aus
der kohle auszusteigen
unklar welche rolle das team später
einmal spielen könnte dies soll kein
schattenkabinett seien unklar auch ob
seine vorstellung zu spät kam um eine
trendwende für die union zu erreichen
fragen wir unsere hauptstadt
korrespondent in chuck und sarah
banerjee kann armin laschet das ruder
noch rumreißen
also man kann ihn und die union auf
jeden fall noch nicht abschreiben denn
drei wochen sind in einem wahlkampf eine
sehr lange zeit da kann relativ viel
passieren und wir haben bei spd und
grünen schon gesehen wie schnell auch
stimmungen wechseln können und sich dann
die richtung der umfragen ändern kann
aber für einen kompletten neustart einer
kampagne ist es jetzt doch schon sehr
spät zumal wir heute auch gesehen haben
das nicht ganz klar ist in welcher rolle
dieses zukunftsteam darauf tritt sie
sind ja ausdrücklich nicht gedacht als
künftige ministerinnen oder minister
möglicherweise mit ausnahme von
friedrich merz den man da eine besondere
rolle zuschreibt und damit bleibt die
stärkste botschaft des heutigen tages
das stärkste signal was so übrig bleibt
dass das die union jetzt nicht mehr auf
armin laschet alleine setzt ihn eben
nicht mehr alleine zutraut das ruder
rumzureißen
immer mehr wähler geben ja auch ihre
stimme per brief ab was bedeutet das für
den wahlkampf
das macht es für alle parteien
komplizierter und auch ein bisschen
anstrengender denn das was früher
traditionell der wahl endspurt war dass
man damals zwei wochen da sagen jetzt
alle es sind jetzt vier wochen
eigentlich hätten alle ihre wichtigsten
botschaften schon vor beginn der
briefwahl an den wähler und die wählerin
bringen müssen also schon vor ungefähr
spätestens anderthalb wochen wer das
noch nicht geschafft hat für den ist es
jetzt zu spät jede stimme die schon im
briefumschlag abgegeben worden ist steht
fest die kann man nicht mehr zu sich
herüberziehen und diejenigen die jetzt
momentan in den umfragen nicht besonders
gut da stehen die kriegen jetzt noch
einmal zusätzlichen stress der einzige
trost ist wahrscheinlich dass man auch
mit fehltritten keine stimme mehr
verlieren kann die bei der briefwahl
schon abgegeben bleiben ist danke nach
berlin konnte the energy
schauen wir auf die lage in afghanistan
dort wollten die taliban heute
eigentlich ihre regierung vorstellen
doch offensichtlich sind sich die neuen
machthaber noch nicht einig und die
humanitäre und wirtschaftliche krise des
landes verschärft sich warnen die
vereinten nationen den menschen fehle es
nahezu an allem hunderttausende sind auf
der flucht vor allem frauen fürchten um
ihre rechte und ihre freiheit ja blase
berichtet sie warten vergebens auf
arbeit tagelöhner an einem sammelpunkt
in kabul seit die taliban an der macht
sind gebe es weniger verbrechen sagen
sie es sei sicherer geworden aber davon
werden sie nicht satt wir sitzen den
ganzen tag rum es gibt keine jobs wir
verdienen kein geld und alles ist so
teuer geworden ein sack mehl kostet
jetzt doppelt soviel gut 20 euro wir
haben keine arbeit was sollen wir tun
die preise steigen viele güter sind
knapp die wirtschaft ist in der krise
viel arbeit für die neue regierung der
taliban geführt werden soll sie so heißt
es von mullah baradar baradar ist einer
der mitbegründer der taliban saß mehrere
jahre in pakistanischer gefangenschaft
kam dann frei und leitete die
verhandlungen die im vergangenen jahr
zur friedensvereinbarung von doha
führten er gilt als pragmatiker in kabul
und anderen orten des landes
demonstrierten heute einige frauen
dagegen dass nur männer im neuen
kabinett sitzen werden und forderten für
sich eine aktive rolle in der politik
die taliban sollen die fortschritte die
wir auf verschiedenen gebieten gemacht
haben respektieren wie im sport oder bei
den frauenrechten unser appell geht an
die neue regierung und die ganze
weltgemeinschaft
es kam kurz darauf zu einem handgemenge
mit einigen taliban kämpfern die frauen
aber konnten ihre demonstration später
fortsetzen es scheint dass nun die
grenzen ausgetestet werden um zu sehen
wie weit kritiker und presse unter dem
neuen regime gehen können
die neue regierung in afghanistan ist
finanziell aufs ausland angewiesen drei
viertel der staatsausgaben kamen über
ausländische hilfen die eu-außenminister
haben jetzt konkrete bedingungen für
eine zusammenarbeit mit den taliban
formuliert bei ihrem treffen in
slowenien machten sie aber auch klar
direkte zahlungen an die neuen
machthaber soll es nicht geben
anne gellinek ist dabei in kran in so
wenigen wie wir die eu mit den taliban
umgehen
die eu außenminister haben sich hier in
slowenien heute auf einer art
diplomatischen drahtseilakt verständigt
sie haben harte bedingungen formuliert
an die neue taliban regierung ohne die
kein geld fließen könne die bedingungen
sind dass sich die islamisten dass die
islamisten menschen und frauenrechte
achten sollen dass sie möglichst viele
gruppen der afghanischen gesellschaft in
der regierung in die regierung
einschließen sollen und dass sie keinen
unterschlupf bieten sollen für
terrororganisationen wie al-kaida
andererseits fürchten die europäer aber
nichts mehr als den kompletten
wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruch in
afghanistan der vermutlich eine
flüchtlingswelle für die nachbarländer
und irgendwann dann auch für europa nach
sich ziehen würde deshalb bleibt der eu
im grunde eigentlich gar nichts anderes
übrig als finanziell mit den taliban
zusammenzuarbeiten und sie zu
unterstützen heiko maas sagte heute
abend man habe keine illusionen man
wisse schon dass nicht hundert prozent
der forderungen von den taliban
umgesetzt werden würden aber man hoffe
doch auf gewisse signale der neuen
regierung und so befindet sich die eu
heute abend nach dem
außenministertreffen in einer zwickmühle
zwischen eigenem anspruch und der
wirklichkeit
dankeschön
zurück nach deutschland sieben wochen
nach der flutkatastrophe hat kanzlerin
merkel erneut das ahrtal besucht in
altenburg machte sie sich ein bild vom
stand der aufräumarbeiten
allein in rheinland pfalz kamen bei der
flut im juli 134 menschen ums leben
merkel sprach den bewohnern mut für den
wiederaufbau zu man werde alles für eine
schnellstmögliche und reibungslose
unterstützung tun wir versuchen so
unbürokratisch wie möglich grund und
land gemeinsam die dinge zu bearbeiten
das ist das was wir tun können und
ansonsten wissen wir dass sie eine tolle
bevölkerung ist tolle bürgermeister von
der ortsgemeinde von der
verbandsgemeinde alle versuchen
zusammenzustellen
thema corona jetzt da sollen arbeitgeber
künftig in bestimmten bereichen ihre
mitarbeiter fragen dürfen ob sie gegen
das virus geimpft sind etwa in
pflegeheimen schulen und kitas auf
diesen kompromiss haben sich union und
spd geeinigt der bundestag muss noch
grünes licht geben das recht auf diese
impf abfrage soll nur so lange gelten
wie eine epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite festgestellt ist und das sind
die aktuellen corona zahlen das robert
koch institut meldet 14 1251
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind
2222 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents steigt auf 80,2 innerhalb
eines tages kamen
554 corona infizierte neu ins
krankenhaus die sieben tage incident
vier 1,83
derzeit infizieren sich vor allem kinder
und jugendliche und das führt dazu dass
schon wieder zehntausende nicht in die
schule dürfen weil sie unter quarantäne
stehen denn es eine in der klasse krank
muss auch der oder die daneben sitzende
14 tage nach hause oder gar die ganze
klasse einheitliche regeln gibt es
bislang nicht wie das in nordrhein
westfalen läuft zeigt dort der färber
das ist die aufgabe 5
homeschooling in quarantäne bei familie
edel die mutter hat uns ein handy video
geschickt für marie war nach vier
spieltagen auf dem neuen gymnasium
wieder schluss nun muss die zehnjährige
zu hause bleiben trotz negativer
pcr-test ein mitschüler ist positiv
getestet worden und das heißt 14 tage
quarantäne für die banknachbarin frei
testen unmöglich
wir merken natürlich auch dass sie sich
sehr eingeschränkt fühlt sie darf das
haus nicht verlassen sie das sich nur
auf unserem grundstück bewegen bei einer
14-tägigen quarantäne in dieser
situation fehlt mir das verständnis für
die verhältnismäßigkeit wie marie sind
jetzt 30.000 schülerinnen und schüler in
nordrhein-westfalen in quarantäne
lehrer sind besorgt denn manche
gesundheitsämter schicken ganze klassen
heimstatt nur die bank nachbarn
steht zu befürchten dass die zahl der
schülerinnen schüler das ist nicht nur
10.000 sein werden sondern erst am ende
des tages hunderttausende schülerinnen
und schüler sprechen die
bildungsministerin unter druck viele in
quarantäne und das auch noch lange sie
will nun eine änderung
ich würde es begrüßen wenn der bund sich
zusammen mit dem robert koch institut
darauf verständigen könnte dass wir eben
tatsächlich am ende des tages nur die
infizierte person in quarantäne schicken
für familie edel wollte spät mehr als
eine woche quarantäne hat marie schon
hinter sich
vor gericht wollte die deutsche bahn den
streik der gewerkschaft gdl stoppen und
ist erneut gescheitert das hessische
landesarbeitsgericht hat den antrag in
zweiter instanz abgelehnt damit geht der
ausstand weiter wie geplant und zwar bis
nächsten dienstag im moment fallen im
fernverkehr gut drei viertel aller
verbindungen aus im regional und s
bahnverkehr wurden knapp 60 prozent der
züge gestrichen
eine alternative zur bahn zumindest auf
kurzen strecken ist das e-bike die
nachfrage steigt seit jahren in der
pandemie ist der absatz geradezu
explodiert ende 2020 waren gut 7,1
millionen
rhede auf deutschen straßen unterwegs im
ersten halbjahr 21 kamen nach
branchenschätzungen noch mal 1,2
millionen dazu doch wer ein e bike
kaufen will der braucht nicht nur geld
sondern auch geduld sandra susanka
spontan so ein e bike kaufen derzeit
fast unmöglich wartezeit oft mehr als
ein halbes jahr auf der weltweit größten
fahrradmesse der eurobike stellt die
branche gerade neuheiten vor unter
anderem leichtere e bikes und
universeller zu machen und jetzt gibt es
einen gegentrend dass ich einen
dezenteren abt im rahmen und kleinen
motor hinten und das sorgt dafür dass
die räder einfach 5 68 kilo leichter
sein können und für so diese 30
kilometer innenstadt fahren die man an
so einem tag hat auch auf knapp 40
prozent der verkauften fahrräder in
deutschland sind mittlerweile e bikes im
schnitt werden dafür 3000 euro
ausgegeben die branche würde gern noch
mehr verkaufen doch die produktion ist
derzeit extrem schwierig es fehlt an
stahl und aluminium weil immer noch
hochöfen still stehen es dauert viel
länger teile aus der welt her zu
bekommen sie sind viel teurer bestimmte
rohstoffe gibt es gar nicht mehr das
geht dann so weit dass wir selbst in den
hochwassergebieten wichtiger messing
produzent sitzt selbst da probleme haben
plötzlich mitten in deutschland anteile
zu kommen dazu kommen logistikprobleme
pro container zahlen die hersteller
mittlerweile das zwanzigfache wie vor
pandemie beginn fahrräder werden deshalb
teurer bis zu zehn prozent
frühestens in einem jahr rechnen
experten mit der normalisierung des
marktes bis dahin müssen sich kunden
wohl noch auf lange wartezeiten
einstellen
ein supertag wieder für das deutsche
team bei den paralympics norbert fünf
medaillen gab es beginnen wir mit der
leichtathletik da gab es den kompletten
medaillensatz bronze für alli lassen
über 200 meter silber für irgendwen
susan über 100 meter und gold für einen
überragenden johannes floss über 400
meter vor fünf jahren verletzte er sich
beim jubel nach dem staffel wettbewerb
viel für seine parade-disziplin aus
triumphiert johannes flores über 400
meter ungefährdet
ein glänzender tag für ihn und für sie
irmgard bensusan gewinnt ihre insgesamt
fünfte paralympische silbermedaille nach
der hälfte des rennens auf goldkurs am
ende knapp geschlagen von der
niederländerin marlene fang ganze winkel
den medaillensatz komplett macht alila
gene über 200 meter bronze gewinnt der
berliner am vorletzten tag der
paralympischen leichtathletik
wettbewerbe
[Musik]
und weiter im heutigen medaillenreigen
zum dritten mal bronze für verena schott
diesmal über 100 meter rücken und silber
für sportschützen natascha hiltrop im
dreistellungskampf
natascha hiltrop verpasst ihr zweites
gold bei diesen paralympics denkbar
knapp es war der letzte schuss nur
dieser nicht ganz perfekt getroffen im
kleinkaliber dreistellungskampf trotz
zuvor 0,8 ringen vorsprung wird es
silber für die in komplett
querschnittsgelähmte hiltrop hinter der
chinesin tier pink sie kann es kaum
fassen verena schott holt über die 100
meter rücken gedrehtes bronze über
diesen paralympics die in komplett
querschnittsgelähmte berlinerin
unterbietet mit einer furiosen
aufholjagd als dritter sogar noch die
bisherige weltrekord zeit gold mit neuem
weltrekord für die us-amerikanerin
elisabeth marx
die deutschen springreiter haben bei
ihrer heim-em in riesenbeck silber im
nationenpreis gewonnen die deutsche
mannschaft lang lag lange zeit im
vorderfeld dann die entscheidung durch
schlussreiter david will der letzte
abwurf des team liebe tanten war dann
einer zu viel der titel ging erstmals
seit 2009 an die schweiz
erstes spiel erster sieg mehr aber auch
nicht die premiere vom bundestrainer
hansi flick eher glanzlos durch die tore
von timo werner in der 41 die häuser in
der 77 minute gewinnt die dfb elf zwar
gestern abend das wm quali spiel in
liechtenstein aber insgesamt jedoch das
deutsche spiel ohne esprit
das war es vom sport dankeschön das
wetter wird sonnig und für viele auch
noch mal richtig warum die details hat
gleich katja riefler slomka begrüßte um
10 im heute-journal danke für ihr
interesse wir wünschen ihnen ein richtig
schönes wochenende und sind morgen
wieder das auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute gab es wieder
eine hochnebeldecke wie allerdings riss
doch dann auseinander sie sehen hier
ganz schön wie hoch nehmen von der
ostsee auch richtung polen zog und dann
diese große hochnebeldecke über der
nordsee von den kräftigen unwetter über
südwesteuropa bekommen wir so gut wie
gar nichts mit aber doch ein kleines
bisschen schon die luft ist feucht und
so gab es heute nachmittag über dem
schwarzwald tatsächlich mal ein gewitter
aber die schauer- und gewitterneigung
bleibt doch eher gering uns ist es in
der nacht meist klar in gewässernähe
bildet sich wieder nebel und in
norddeutschland gibt es auch wieder eine
hochnebeldecke die temperaturen dazu
sinken auf 13 bis 7 grad und steigen
morgen im breisgau bis 27 grad deutlich
kühler bleibt es an der ostsee mit nur
18 grad denn auch morgen gibt es in
norddeutschland wieder so eine
hochnebeldecke wie sollte sich rasch
auflösen viel mehr sonnenschein aber
gibt es in süddeutschland da gibt es
höchstens dekorative kleine quellwolken
und der sonntag bringt uns ein ganz
ähnliches bild bei ähnlichen
temperaturen und ähnlich schön startet
dann auch die neue woche wir haben es
einfach weiterhin mit diesem schönen
spätsommer wetter zu tun guten abend